zardari 5 había estado viviendo en esta
aldea en el estado de punjab durante más
de 20 años su esposa sarah y sus
dos hijos el granjero se ganaba la vida
cultivando trigo y algodón pero su
pequeña parcela de tierra apenas le
permitía alimentar a su familia en 2015
en sus vidas estaban destrozadas sino de
sus arcas no se suicidó una hectárea de
tierra no es suficiente para vivir
habíamos comprado un tractor pero
perdimos nuestras cosechas ese año lo
deprimió mucho además tuvimos que pedir
prestado casi cinco mil dólares para
pagar los préstamos anteriores y
vertidos del iudop está venga de ciudad
una deuda que se hizo insoportable para
ver quién se ahorcó en su casa esta
historia trágica está lejos de ser una
excepción la deuda afecta a más de la
mitad de los 90 millones de hogares
campesinos de la india deben en total
millones de dólares a los bancos y
prestamistas oportunistas que operan en
el sector desde mediados de la década de
1990 al menos 300.000 agricultores se
han suicidado principalmente por una
deuda estar apellido ahora está luchando
para llegar a fin de mes especialmente
con un niño enfermo sin contar los
préstamos para pagar vendemos el forraje
y la leche de nuestras vacas para
sobrevivir pero aquí está mal visto que
las esposas de los granjeros trabajan
fuera tiran jitka ur perdió a su padre
también un granjero desesperado que se
quitó la vida su ong ayuda a las
familias y viudas al revuelo cómo usar
aquí a reclamar una compensación del
gobierno
desde hace tres años estamos luchando
contra todos los problemas que enfrentan
las mujeres es una lucha de largo
aliento
durante su revolución verde a mediados
del diseño de 1960 india aumentó la
producción de alimentos y se volvió
autosuficiente y los agricultores de se
enriquecieron fue una prosperidad
efímera las semillas de alto rendimiento
muy dependientes de los fertilizantes y
plaguicidas químicos obligaron a los
agricultores a que invirtieran cada vez
más las lluvias irregulares y los largos
períodos de sequía también agravaron la
miseria de las familias campesinas
las principales causas del suicidio de
los agricultores son el aumento de los
costos de las semillas agrícolas y los
precios de los fertilizantes
especialmente desde la desregulación de
esos mercados los mangueros esperan
poder vender a precios más altos pero no
siempre es así todo esto conduce a una
caída de los ingresos de los
agricultores y por lo tanto a un aumento
de su deuda
li ting rising internet
la mayoría de los cultivadores venden
sus productos en mercados mayoristas
como este aquí es donde el gobierno
establece los precios de compra de los
cultivos pechos bajos que benefician más
a los consumidores que a los productores
no puedo dormir por la noche porque
vendemos nuestras cosechas por debajo de
su valor le daremos dinero al
terrateniente y al banco nosotros los
agricultores no tendríamos que solicitar
préstamos bancarios si nos pagaran un
precio justo por nuestro trabajo el
gobierno de india acaba de revelar las
reformas que se espera aumenten la
productividad y los ingresos agrícolas
los nuevos textos proponen relajar las
reglas que han protegido a los
agricultores del libre mercado durante
décadas esa decisión desencadena la ira
de los agricultores que se sienten
defraudados por el gobierno y
desamparados ante los actores privados
frente a los manifestantes
el gobierno quiere tranquilizarlo si
promete que sus reformas darán más
opciones a los agricultores
hace unos días liberamos a los
agricultores de nuestro país de muchas
limitaciones ahora nuestros granjeros
pueden vender sus productos en cualquier
lugar y a cualquier persona
[Música]
en el punjab giran la activista que
lucha por las viudas de los agricultores
está al frente de las protestas
creo que si los miembros de este
proyecto se preocuparan realmente por
los problemas de los agricultores no se
habrían comportado como dictadores al
presentar este proyecto de ley sin
consulta
están tratando de vender nuestra tierra
a las grandes empresas del sector
mientras que los debates sobre los
proyectos de ley son intensos los
expertos están de acuerdo en la
necesidad de cambiar las prácticas
agrícolas esta granja cerca de nueva
delhi funciona con un modelo alternativo
y sostenible después de 10 años de
agricultura convencional la familia de
un cual el dakar se pasó a la
agricultura orgánica es arroz 100%
orgánico que hemos plantado usando
semillas que producimos nosotros mismos
no tenemos que comprarlos a terceros si
usáramos pesticidas y fertilizantes
químicos nos costaría 170 euros por
media hectárea lo orgánico nos ahorra
todo ese dinero en la actualidad sólo el
3% de la tierra cultivable de la india
se dedica a la producción orgánica
nuestros agricultores no están
entrenados tenemos que acompañarlos el
gobierno no apoya la agricultura
orgánica los programas gubernamentales
que proponen no están relacionados con
la agricultura
este es nuestro mayor reto hoy
el reto de la agricultura sostenible es
urgente en índia sin este cambio el
futuro del sector que emplea casi la
mitad de los indios se ve sombrío